local organizations are teaming up to
help everyone in the valley get proper
health care at their new centers around
town
sarah from kano rachel from humana you
guys are working together to help our
community out let's talk about
the new centers opening up in las vegas
from kano
perfect yes so we're really excited
we've just opened
three clinics here in las vegas and
planning on branching out some more
uh really what we focus on is our
medicare patients and those that are
underserved in our community
so we want to make sure that we've
created a place where you can come
and feel supported by your clinical care
team where you want to come
and that you feel comfortable and
confident talking with your provider
that's great and i'm what does it mean
to have medicare focus with your centers
so for us medicare focus means that we
are holistic when we look at a patient
we don't want to just see you when you
feel ill
or you think there might be an issue we
really want to build that trust and
relationship with your pcp
so that when you see them that primary
care provider
that they know about you and your health
history and that it's a
teamwork conversation about how to get
you to your healthiest point
in life and make sure that you're living
that out
so we want to make sure that we have
things like social workers
and people to help you in your wellness
center transportation to really help
make that robust system
that works around you as a patient and
works with each of the needs that you
have
awesome and rachel this next question is
for you that was actually the perfect
segue
um why is it important for people not to
skip out on their annual checkup
especially now since people are
a little more hesitant with going into
the doctor's office
exactly and that's why it's important to
focus on preventive
proactive care and not just aches and
pains annual checkups with your primary
care provider may help get to the root
of any problem so it can be taken care
of
before it worsens or before you need to
go to the emergency room
we want our members to truly enjoy the
visits to the doctor and enjoy
compassionate care that goes beyond the
clinical
that's why we've added conno health to
our network i encourage you to learn
more about them
our humana plans and the providers in
our network
awesome and sarah obviously this is
really important information for
medicare for people with medicare
what else should they know about the new
centers in town so we have a lot of new
services that are new to the las vegas
valley
and we also focus on a lot of different
areas that have been
in need and underserved here in las
vegas so we have a number of spanish
speaking and tagalog speaking providers
and staff members
so when you come in we treat you as a
whole person
that you can speak in your preferred
language we have an understanding of
some of your cultural background
and that you can build that trust with
the team as well as some of those things
that i mentioned
earlier with your transportation home
visits
making sure that we're in areas where
you're next to a grocery store so if you
come into our office
you can be empowered to do your grocery
shopping when then get a ride home
instead of waiting for your adult child
to take time off of work
see you guys got everything covered for
us and i love that everyone gets the
chance to have the proper care so thank
you for that
for more information call 1-800-345-8017
or find them online
know health dot com or at health that
cares dot com
las vegas now we'll be right back